welcome back to las vegas now so you've
probably seen him hosting a golden
knights game maybe a raiders game he
somehow manages to be in five places at
once i don't know how he does it but his
biggest project is celebrating an
exciting anniversary next week joining
us today is mark chinook the creator of
monday's dark which has raised over a
million dollars for a variety of
different charity organizations in our
community mark thank you so much for
being here thank you this is an honor to
be here you guys uh have such an amazing
platform and being able to come on and
talk about passion projects is just so
great so thank you so much for uh this
opportunity of course you're a friend of
the show and i have been to several
mondays it's dark before and the
anniversary shows it's always a party
but let's talk about this year eight
years what can people expect you know
it's it's a crazy time obviously but
we're very excited to be able to gather
in such a large scale again
every other week for those of you who
don't know monday's dark partners with a
different local charity we write a check
for ten thousand bucks to that local
group and in december we bring everybody
back from an amazing year of giving we
go to a big room this year at the virgin
hotel inside the virgin theater which is
special for us because that's where
monday's dark started we started at the
hard rock and so to be able to go back
now that it's the virgin is exciting but
like i said i think just the opportunity
to bring a thousand or more 2 000 people
into a theater and celebrate this year
of giving is is something that we're
really looking forward to yeah this year
i think will be bigger and better than
ever people are just excited to be
together again and also you know getting
entertained but also supporting our
organizations and our community and
usually at the anniversary show you kind
of preview what's to come in the next
year right yeah so we bring back the 21
charities that we've partnered with this
year and we announce for the first time
who the 21 charities will be uh for next
year so 42 local organizations under one
roof celebrating each other uh one week
from tonight so it's uh it's a lot of
work we have an incredible team your
sister's on our team
and it's just been it's been a whirlwind
year we're very excited to celebrate and
get people together i just looked up and
saw my crazy mustache on the camera and
this has to go
i wasn't gonna say anything but no you
always look great and
you are no stranger to the stage you've
been you know rock of ages you've been
around in vegas forever are you gonna
get up on the mic and give us something
yeah there will be a little mark chinook
number yes i gotta sing when i get get
that opportunity you know i work
full-time in sports now and i i
definitely miss being on stage full-time
uh so this is an opportunity for me to
sort of let loose a little bit and you
know
jc who's standing over here he's been
such a big supporter of what we got
going on and this is about our community
you know when i moved here nine years
ago now with rock of ages i had no
expectation for something like this so
to be able to to be celebrating eight
years of giving back to our community
it's just a testament to our community
people like yourself and jc and
coming on a show like this and being
able to talk about it is huge well thank
you so much mark and everything you're
doing for the community and tickets are
going fast so real quick tell people
where they can get it and when the show
is and all the fun details
mondaysdark.com
is our website the event is one week
from today december 13th eight o'clock
doors are at seven and tickets are only
20 bucks it's always that way we've
raised 1.4 million for las vegas
20.